Anyway, I think we're on September the 5th, 1922, is that OK?
So the soul who lives in the will of God must implose all creation within herself.
My adorable Jesus comes to make himself seen with his heart pierced and embittered to
the summit.
It seems that all the pains of creatures were inflicted in that heart.
In fact, it's not only since that wound that heart, but also the sufferings that the creature
causes herself by not corresponding with grace, which is very interesting.
And it seems that since they were wounding a heart that loves, as they wounded that loving
heart, its love is so great that it tried to transmute the very offenses into graces and
blessings.
Wow.
If you ever wanted a definition of the goodness of God, you have it there.
Oh, goodness of Jesus.
He alone can boast of really loving the creatures and up to the incredible as well.
So the pains of each one of them also pierced that sacred heart, but the offenses were so
many as to turn the very graces which came from that most holy heart into lightnings.
So you can persevere with the rejection until it comes to a point where it will turn into
chastisement, but initially he wants to turn it all into graces.
So that's a very clear passage that I don't see anywhere else in these writings, where
he first of all says that what comes to him, he wants to give back as grace and blessing.
But if you persevere and persevere and persevere, it will come back to you in chastisement.
Is that what the lightnings mean?
Yeah.
And so he changes my graces into lightnings and drives himself towards a general revolution.
Now this 1922, the general revolution is the Second World War.
So he is the human race we're responsible for the chastisements that come.
So he himself is plotting his own destruction.
We even say that such a such a person is his own worst enemy.
And has reached such a point as to deserve to be struck by me.
And while he was saying this, he showed troubles everywhere, cities collapsed and evils of
a new kind being shown.
Okay.
So afterwards, Jesus came back again, tired, asking for my help in his pains, Louisa said.
And breathing on me again, at the place in my heart, he shared with me the shadows, I
would say, of his pains.
That's all the human being can actually take.
Yet even though they were shadows, had he not remained near me to give me help, I could
not have endured them.
What must be the pains of that most holy heart?
Then Camming himself, he told me, my daughter, first born of my will, since my will encloses
everything, in giving you my will as life, I want to enclose everything also in you.
Remember that a few months ago, you do remember, don't you?
I fixed a little wheel of the sun inside view.
Do you have the reference for that in your book?
No.
It's February the 2nd, 1922, volume 13, February 2, 1922, volume 13.
He fixed a little wheel inside of her, okay?
So I fixed a little wheel inside of you and with the ruler, I measured you all over and
then another little wheel descended from heaven.
And after I fixed that one in you, it kept many threads of light which were fixed in
the most holy trinity.
Everything remained open between you and us and for that time, I left you without giving
you any explanation of my work, he's now going to give the explanation here.
If you don't close the door, it's going to affect the recording.
Everything comes down to the recording, including echo.
I left you without giving you any explanation about my work.
Now, after having worked in you so much during all this time passed and having to complete
my work, that's Philippians 1, 6, the Lord completes what he starts, I want to give you
some explanations so that the seal of my will, you need a heading, the seal of the divine
will on top of your page because the seal is going to come up time and time again.
Now, the seal of the divine will is desperately important if you remember the book of Revelation.
And that before the terrible chastisements of the earth, the elect were to be sealed.
The elect were to be sealed so that the devastation wouldn't come upon them.
And that's around chapter 7.
And when you come into the reign of the Antichrist in chapter 13, then you have everybody who
has not been sealed with the divine seal, gets the seal of the Antichrist and the human
race is turned into two camps.
Okay, so this seal of the divine will is extremely important.
So that the seal of the divine will and of yours becoming one may give completion to
the mission that I have called you.
Now, again, you need a second heading at the top of your page and that is the completion
of Louise's mission because we're going to get the explanation of that as we go along.
And this is the first time he speaks about completing her mission.
So number one, the little wheel of light, which I fixed inside of you, was the whole
of creation, which came out from the divinity, all love, light and beauty.
And then I measured you with the ruler to see your dispositions and those which were
lacking in order to put them in.
To be able to fix the little wheel well and to keep it safe.
So notice the Lord himself looks at whatever is missing.
He will actually fix it up.
It's just like a workman who is trying to do something and sees that something needs
to be adjusted and he just does it.
So the second thing is, the second little wheel was the divinity which descended into
you established that which the divine will had created in heaven and fixed it in you
so as to place itself in the proper relations with that creation order.
So the first little wheel is the whole of creation and the second one is the divine
will and it's going to get these two wheels operating in relation to each other.
Now know that I have enclosed and fixed creation in you.
So you better remember Romans 8 and I think it's 17 and I'm not absolutely certain at
this moment that the whole of creation is waiting for the sons of God to show themselves.
I want that which was done in heaven to have life upon earth but in our own will which
ascending to us again may bring it to us all love full of light and beauty as we delivered
it.
So the divine will is in heaven, the divine will is on earth and Jesus says is now fixed
creation inside of Louisa and the divine will also inside of her so that she can give him
back creation in the divine will which is what he wants.
And you can give it back to us all love light and beautiful as we delivered it.
So this is why I marked you with all the deaths and pains of each creature that means each
soul.
See it's not each creature in the sense animals are creatures.
Okay so it's also humans so souls I think is better there and all souls together that
we would say from Adam to Zachary so that I might find the whole of creation in you
and since heaven remains open between you and us you will bring creation onto our lap
as if it had been delivered to you.
Now he doesn't seem to be talking about creation as the stars and the galacties does he?
He seems to be talking about the human race.
Okay so he's saying to Louisa since we put the divine will inside of you we also put the
human race inside of you and we want you to bring them back to us as they were before
the fall.
Okay so since heaven remains open between you and us you will bring creation onto our lap
as if it were delivered by you that is as a birth from our will made by you which you
bring back to our feet delivering it on our lap.
Now the language is very interesting because in the ancient world the birth of an infant
was onto the lap of the husband.
One of the wonderful images that I have somewhere is a birth in Africa according to the ancient
rules and there was nobody in the the hot except the husband and the wife and she was
in a kind of a semi-sitting position standing, I don't know what you call that, crouching
and he was sitting with his legs under her ready to receive the infant.
His most beautiful image of oneness and there was an extraordinary beauty about it and simplicity.
See the birth made into our lap you know using very ancient language there which I think
is lovely.
These are our rights that we claim.
All we want is that which came out from us to enter into us.
It's true that our will alone acting in the soul has with its power just as it acted in
that void when we delivered creation will be able to give us back our rights.
In other words only the divine will can do this.
I mean Louisa as an individual or any one of us as an individual couldn't do this but
the divine will acting in us can do it hence how important it is for us to open up to the
fullness of the divine will.
But we want to use this power so that we may not remain disappointed in the work of creation
and our love triumphs bore in taking from one creature that which all should give us.
So he has said this over and over again that when he works he works the entire process
through one person as our blessed mother in redemption and Louisa in the kingdom of the
divine will and once it absolutely completed in them then others can enter in as deeply
as they want to go.
Now we are fixing everything in you or I should say now we are fixing everything in
you before it was in the blessed mother.
The other little birds will be delivered which loving to live in this way of the divine will
bring into our lap some of them 10, some of them 20, some of them 100 measures okay.
Do you remember the parable of the sower Matthew 13, some bring forth 30, 60 or 100%.
Now these are us the other little birds and we can respond at different levels but the
100% is demanded of Louisa so that we can enter in as well as we can.
You will be like a tree which has sunk its deep roots in our will and these roots will
make other saplings germinate which surrounding the tree like a crown will produce its fruits.
It's very interesting because Jesus is using the same imagery about himself in Matthew 7.
Matthew 7, 16 are the fruits Matthew 13, 8 is the producing 10, 20 and 100 fold and so
on.
And Jesus had compared himself to a mustard seed that would become a great tree didn't
he and he also compared himself to the vine so he's using exactly the same language here
and that is because he himself is the vine and we are the branches so he's working through
one of his branches on the vine.
True good never remains isolated Jesus said and since my will is the greatest good its
fecundity will be immense therefore courage be attentive in everything it's true that
our will will do everything I desire it he does it okay.
But the thread of your will must run together with the divine will and extend into heaven
on earth and in everything to let us accomplish what we want to operate in you.
So this wonderful thing can only happen if the divine will is actually carrying it out
but we have to give him the space we have to give him the kingdom inside of us is that
all right.
So September the ninth 1922 in creating man God formed a kingdom for himself that's Luke
what is it now Luke 17 21 the kingdom of God is within you okay.
So my ever sweet Jesus continues to speak about his most holy will he showed his heart
opened and from which many rivelets of light now he himself is the light John 8 12 and
nine five I am the light of the world John 8 12 and nine five.
So many rivelets of light came out which wounded all souls and formed a net of light
overwhelming everything and he began to speak telling me my daughter in creating the first
man I gave a start to the creation of mankind and after I formed his body with my omnipotent
breath I infused in him the soul Genesis 2 7 and with another breath of mine I could
say I infused myself into the depths of man in order to say in him dominate him and keep
him safe so it put Genesis 1 27 there made in his image okay.
So that man formed a kingdom for me now a kingdom is a space to work in it's a place
where somebody is going to rain where an awful lot is going to be accomplished but at the
moment I just want to think in terms of space that I give him the space to do what he wants.
So that man formed a kingdom for me and I as king was to extend my boundaries.
My joy reached the summit in seeing in this man the generation almost endless of other
beings they're all the creatures coming out of Adam I saw the generation almost endless
of many other beings that would provide me with many other kingdoms for as many creatures
as would come to the light in whom I was to rain and to expand my divine boundaries.
So you think of God creating all of these souls and what he wanted was to be able to
rain as king in every single one of them okay.
And all the good of the other kingdoms was to flow for the glory and honor of the first
kingdom which is Adam he's the first one made isn't he.
Which was to be the head of the others he was the constitute of the head of the human
race and as though the prime act of creation.
But as man withdrew from my will my kingdom and his ended.
Now notice and his either God reigns or no one reigns so if it isn't God it's emptiness
and I'm sure you've looked into at least some people's eyes and seen that awful emptiness
where there's absolutely nothing there.
Not only this but he trampled me and he placed himself to rain in my place idolatizing himself
that's autology the worship of self and the final insult to God idolatizing himself and
forming the reign of vices, miseries and disasters.
My joy died at birth and turned into sorrow.
Now the one thing that the human race gave to God that he didn't have before was sorrow.
Okay that's our gift to God sorrow.
See all evil was in his withdrawal from my will.
So that's the creation and now we've got to come to the recovery which is redemption.
Now as we go on in these writings the Lord is going to give us these explanations but
more and more expanded as we go along okay.
So for redemption I want to give you Hebrews 4, 15.
So I put A for creation and B for redemption.
Our love did not stop because God is love and naturally his nature doesn't change.
I didn't want to be an isolated God, no.
Therefore I wanted to descend from heaven taking on a humanity similar to the first man.
Now please put a note there not degenerate man, similar to the first man before his fall
because he was in the divine will wasn't he okay.
I enclosed all of creation in this humanity.
I bound the human will of this humanity to the divine will so this is Christ talking
about his own humanity so that this human will embracing all creation and all of their
acts within the divine will might bring it to my throne as triumphant over all human acts
which had been changed by it into acts of the divine will and there you have the redoing
of all acts and turning all acts into divine acts.
With this the human will took possession of the divine will and the divine took possession
of the human.
Now it happened in Jesus first and then in others afterwards one lording over the other.
In fact when one being forms one single thing with another one if one is Lord the other
two becomes Lord almost naturally because it's mutual giving.
The only reason for which I had commanded man to abstain from the fruit prohibited by
me was this this is very interesting now this is an explanation of this bit of Genesis you
won't get anywhere else.
I wanted an act of sacrifice of his will in mine.
Know that through this sacrifice binding his human will with mine he might take possession
of my will and I of his and both might reign with the same power that's the father wisdom
the son and goodness the Holy Spirit.
So to reign in Christ is Romans 5 17.
So Adam was told that he was Lord of the earth and he could reign over everything but
he was supposed to do it in the divine will not outside of it.
In nothing I wanted him dissimilar from me he was a birth from me he was my son think
of Luke 15 he was my son and what father does not love his son want his son to be rich
and happy as he is more so for me the celestial father who would lose nothing in rendering
this son of mine rich happy and raining with me.
So the Lord wanted all of this that's the father of the son now the reason I gave you
Luke 15 is you know the son is now the prodigal son okay so what was the thing that the Lord
wanted to produce through redemption it was to produce another Christ.
So as man broke his will from mine my love did not remain quiet but raised its flames
higher.
You see this very much in every detail of the crucifixion of Jesus when he is hanging
on the cross and Louisa describes it very well in the hours of the passion that every
challenge thrown to Jesus his love rose higher his love rose higher his love rose higher
and higher until it reached the level that could not be reached by any other human being.
So he raised his flames higher the flames now are flames of love and at any cost I wanted
to produce another me.
So I chose my humanity which sacrificing itself to my will in everything now notice the everything
the mistake we make is that we do it in some things took possession of my will letting
me accomplish within itself the purpose of the creation of man which is to bring all
things back to the father in his will.
In fact my usual way is to carry out my greatest enterprises in one person alone and then I
diffuse them okay it's good to write person there in one person alone.
Was it not one man Adam that ruined all my designs and so my humanity alone that is
Christ was to repay me for this ruin Romans chapters four to six four five six Paul gives
you wonderful teaching on this.
So was it not my humanity alone that was to repay me for this ruin and the power of my
will in closing all creation in it was to return to me the loves the kisses the caresses
which the first man had so brutally rejected.
Now it's unrequited love that is being dealt with.
One of the greatest martyrdoms on the planet as you know my love laying down the garments
I would say of sorrow and of mourning clothed it itself anew in feast and triumphant gave
itself to the greatest excesses and follies of love.
I want to give you John 10 29 and 39 29 and 39 so when I want to do a work with any human
being I always begin one on one and if no as if no one else existed and then I extended
so much as to fill the heavens and the earth okay.
So now we come to number three which is sanctification so creation redemption sanctification.
Now my daughter my love wants to produce again and while it gives in to excesses it goes
out taking a break it wants to deliver new births taking a break was only 2000 years
of course it's nothing for him and just as it operated in my humanity and closing all
of creation in it so that it might give to the father everything he wanted from it and
let everything descend for the good of all people.
So now binding your will with mine we're talking about Louisa I want to enclose all
of creation in you and letting you take possession of my will I want to feel my act my love my
pains being repeated in you I want my reflector on earth so a person on earth who actually
reflects him so I want to give you wisdom 7 26.
I want to give you one Corinthians 13 12 and he's going to continue talking about reflections
so two Corinthians 3 18 because in two Corinthians 3 18 Paul says you become like what you worship
the more you contemplate God the more you're transformed into his image so I want my reflector
on the earth so that in looking at it I may see in you as though in a mirror that's your
one Corinthians 13 12 the creation which I created in heaven and which my humanity enclosed
within itself and in reflecting myself in this mirror I may recognize creation in you.
We will be in continuous mutual reflections we use we use the same message but not using
those words we say somebody becomes more and more Christ like that means a reflection of
Christ on the earth okay and the more we become that the more he can work through us okay so
I will make creation be reflected in you and you in me I from heaven and you from the earth
then my love will be content John 15 9 as the father has loved me so I have loved you
then my love will be content when I see in a human being not only the image of my humanity
but all that my divine will operated in it he wants to see this miracle therefore be attentive
and follow my will September the 11th 1922 the primary purpose of all that God is done in
creation and redemption is that the creature would live in the divine will okay that's that
was what he was at so continue in my usual state I was abandoning all of myself in the
holy will of my sweet Jesus and feeling the need to rest I said to myself also my sleep
in your will hope you don't forget that one I want nothing else but to take true rest in
the arms of your volition and Jesus said daughter lay your rest as a mantle over all creatures
so as to cover them all because only in my will is their true rest now that mantle that
you throw over everybody else will enable them somehow to come and sleep properly instead
of sleeping in sin okay I want to give you a couple of scriptures for rest Hebrews chapter
three verse seven to chapter four verse 11 there's a big thing on rest there chapter
three seven to four eleven okay I want to give you Sam one three one that's resting in
the arms of the Lord okay there's lots more as well but because that's a long teaching
in Hebrews three to four I'll just give you that one so Jesus says only in my will is
their true rest and since the divine will envelops everything and you rest in my divine
will you will lay yourself over all souls in order to infiltrate true rest for them all
Matthew 11 28 the invitation to come and rest in the Sacred Heart how beautiful it is to
see a creature of ours resting in the arms of our will but in order to find true rest
it's necessary that she put all of her acts her words her love her desires etc on the
way within our will that means fuse fuse everything in the divine will so that as they
take their place in the divine will they may receive rest and I may rest in them only
when they are fulfilled then do all works give rest but if they're not fulfilled they
always give some concern something to do and renders the person true rest restless okay
so the subject here is huge absolutely huge I'll just hint at it Genesis 1 you have the
seventh day was the day of rest after the labor of creation okay just put the seventh
day then when you come to John's gospel there is a seven day recreation account and
John's gospel and what confuses people when you begin to show them this seven day recreation
account in John's gospel is that day six is missing why is day six missing because that
was the day man was created and he's already there so you don't have to have a another
day in fact the whole of the gospel is the recreation of the human race all right and
the day that Jesus was buried was the most solemn Sabbath that there could be because
it was Passover okay and it was his day of rest after the labor of redemption okay and
the third one is that when souls come to truly rest in God in the divine will the Lord says
he's home and try he rested after creation he rested after redemption and the final rest
is when souls come to dwell in the divine will that make sense now you could go on a lot
on that subject because as you can see I've given you Genesis to revelation nearly okay
it's a huge subject and so the rest that's spoken about here then is called the Sabbath
day rest and the Sabbath day rest is your work for six days and you're supposed to rest on
the seventh and the Sabbath day rest is supposed to remind you of where you're going after
the labors of your life because heaven is the Sabbath day rest see how big the subject
is so I'm only throwing it actually just in outlines just to give you some idea of what
is being touched on here the seventh day rest and when we speak of people who have passed
over to the other side we say may they rest in peace well that's their Sabbath day rest
okay so as I say there's an awful lot could be said about that but I'm going to go on
so Jesus says now the fulfillment of the work of creation was that man you'd say the purpose
of the work of creation was that man would fulfill our will in everything because the
word first word fulfillment seems to be wrong there the purpose of the work of creation
was that man would fulfill our will in everything our will was to be the life the food and the
crown of human beings and since it's not yet so the work of creation is not yet fulfilled
and neither can I rest in it the Lord says and neither can it rest in me now that should
be a small it because it's creation resting in the Lord is that okay and it always gives
me something to do and I yearn for this fulfillment and rest so this is why I love and want so
much that the way of living in my will be known I want you to know every time he says
he wants it to be known because that's a subject we're going to have to look at so I want my
will to be known put a big marker around that nor will I ever be able to say that the works
of creation and redemption are fulfilled if I do not have all the acts of the human being
extending in my will just note what he's saying there all the acts not some all the act extending
in my will like a bed to give me rest of what beautiful rest shall I not give to the soul
in seeing her coming back on the wings of our will is not lovely with the seal of the fulfillment
of creation now do you see seal again okay you want you to note that one of the fulfillment
of creation my womb will be her bed now my womb means the heart of the blessed Trinity
okay so you just put the heart of the blessed Trinity there therefore there is nothing that
I did which did not have as its primary purpose that man would take possession of my will and
I of his this was my primary purpose in creation and the same in redemption the sacraments I
instituted the many graces given by my saints have been seeds means to let man reach the
possession of my will therefore neglect nothing of what I want about my will either with writing
or with words or with works okay that's because he wants it known from this alone you can know
that the living in my will is the greatest thing the most important that which interests me the most
you will know this from the many preparations that have preceded it as well and you want to know
where this seed of my will is sewn its own in Jesus's humanity in it in Jesus's humanity it
germinated was born and grew this seed can be seen in Jesus's wounds and in his blood wanting to
be transplanted into the human being so that the soul may take possession of the divine will and
Jesus said and I of hers so that the whole of creation may return to the origin from which it
came now that's where we're going back to the beginning okay and so we've to pick up from where
Adam left off just as it came out not only through my humanity but also through the creature herself
now in the next paragraph he says it's not going to be a few there'll be an army of souls
okay just as you look up into the heavens and you see an army of stars okay you see an army of
galacties anything that God does God is rich beyond riches and so the number of galacties we know of
is a hundred billion and counting the number of stars is beyond counting because there's at least
a billion stars in the Milky Way alone there may even be more do you know what I mean so the sheer
immensity of what God does is beyond us and so he says there will be his army of souls in the
divine will as well that's necessary to try and bring the rest of them around okay but at the same
time they will be few because it won't be everybody is that okay and and since he's talking to
Louisa way ahead of the rest of us hearing about it he said even if there was only one
was it not one who withdrawing from my will disfigured and broke my plans and destroyed
the purpose of creation that's Adam of course one destroyed it in the same way only one can
adorn it and fulfill its purpose however my works never remain isolated so I will have the army of
the souls who will live in my will so he come he completes everything in Louisa just as as he
completed everything in blessed mother for redemption but he will have his army just as he's had his
army of saints from the church as well so I will have the army of the souls who will live in my will
and in them I will have my creation restored is now wonderful now if you want to look that up
I want to give you an exercise you look up do you know how to look up stuff in the Bible
you look up new heavens and new earth okay new heavens and new earth and you'll find there's an
enormous amount of references to it in the New Testament and I mean enormous there'll be new
heavens and new earth so I will have my creation restored all beautiful and striking just as it
came out of my hands otherwise I would not have so much interest in making my will known in other
words if this wasn't going to happen won't be the point in all the effort okay so September the 15
1922 you must give it a heading make divine will known and we're going to get more and more of
this okay make divine will known continue to let copying be done from my writings of what Jesus
has told me on the virtues Louisa said I was feeling such a repugnance as to feel I was dying
and I said to myself others have the inventory of their tings done after their death I'm the only
one that has the heart a lot of having to do it myself while I'm still alive it's not fair okay
but of course the others weren't involved in making a completely new revelation to the earth
and nobody else could do it all or she said give me the strength to make this sacrifice
and then in addition to this the confessor let me know the way that must be followed
when they put them out and she said what pain I felt embittered deep into the marrow of my bones
and blessed Jesus on coming seeing me so embittered said to me my daughter what is it
why do you afflict yourself so much it is my glory my honor that demands this and you should
be happy about it and do you think that it is the human beings that want this that do this and that
command you no no he said I have to overwhelm them all I find that very interesting I have to
overwhelm everything I have to push them I have to enlighten them and after all his overwhelming
and pushing and enlightening and everything when Louisa died what did they do with her writings
dump them in the Vatican is where they where they dump all the wonderful writings of the saints
until somebody comes along they want to rescue them and it wasn't until 1994 that a group of
priests and lay people actually went and rescued the writings of Louisa but the Vatican wasn't
concerned it's fascinating that's why the Lord says I have to overwhelm everything I have to
push it I've got to make it happen many times he said I'm not listened to otherwise I mean look at
Faustina's writings as well they were dumped in the Vatican as well until John Paul came along
and rescued him just to give two modern examples many times I'm not listened to he said otherwise
they would hasten more and more and they would show more interest and I'm forced to push them
more strongly so that my will will be accomplished what is this thing in the modern church that is
not interested in spiritual writings you actually know the answer to it it's the modernism rationalism
and all of this liberalism and everything that took over and these writings represent
the way the Lord thinks not the way the moderns think so they weren't interested in this kind of
writing and they didn't realize that God was really speaking to them that's the frightening bit
and you would rather wait jesus said I'd laugh to your death but my will doesn't want to wait
besides it's true that you have the link and the graft with my will but here it's actually not
about you it's about me it's not it's about the divine will it's about making known the effects
the qualities and the value contained in my will now you need to put a marker beside that
what exactly are we telling people it's the effects the qualities the value contained in the
divine will operating in the creature so that she can actually live in it confidently okay
and then if you do not want to interest yourself jesus said
you who know how much i care and how i ardently yearn for the effects of my will to be known
from which i will receive the complete glory of creation and the fulfillment of redemption itself
oh how many effects are still suspended both in creation and redemption now we're only in volume
14 and she's got to go to volume 36 lewisa still doesn't know the half of it do you know what i mean
he has so much more to actually reveal to her um because my will is not known
that's the issue okay my will is not known and doesn't have its true kingdom in the human being
the human heart and since it does not reign the human will remains always the slave of itself
so if the divine will isn't revealed then the human will doesn't even know that it's enslaved
and doesn't know that it needs to be set free oh how many things uh or do you think that others
will interest themselves after your death oh how many things which i have manifested to souls are
buried that's buried in the the bank of the the vatican okay for lack of those who would
interest themselves in my works and probably you know if they ever do an overhaul of the 350
miles of shelves in the vatican that an awful lot of stuff will come up that they just simply dumped
there 350 you know it's all on did you yeah 350 miles of shelves so there's there's a lot of places
to bury stuff in the vatican and just forget about them and for lack of those who would interest
themselves in my work but if i have tolerated this with other things notice that in other words i
let them off with it a few times i will not tolerate it with my will i will give so much grace to those
who will put themselves to work and that they will not be able to resist me but the most interesting
and essential part he said will come from you now i love the way he says the most interesting
bit is to come from you the rest of us you see are only trying to understand what was said to
louisa and to try and put it across and no matter what we do we can't match louisa you don't even
try yeah okay so september the 20th 1922 this is life in the divine will if you want a heading
and a second heading is self-lessness self-fishness doesn't fit in divine will that's just the way it is
i was saying to my beloved jesus oh please my love let it be so that nothing but love
praise reparation and blessing towards you may come from all of my being now while i was saying
this blessed jesus came and i saw myself all eyes there was not a particle in me that one could
not see an eye now it's very interesting because there's an image like this in the book of revelation
you're told that the lord had eyes all over the place that means all seeingness and there was
not a particle of me in which one could not see an eye and from from each of them array of light
came out which wounded the person of our lord and he said to me my daughter it's right and proper
the word in my book is decorous it's right and proper for me and for you that nothing but love
sanctity glory all for me come out of you otherwise i would degrade my will by letting his soul live in
it who is not a complete complex of all the goods with which my will overbounds now all those goods
you've met them before wisdom understanding council fortitude knowledge all the fruits of the spirit
and all the rest of it and all the sanctity and divine will everything that comes from the lord
so you have to be a complex of all of this and the thing that binds all of them together is love
he's told us that many times and if the soul did not have the seeds of all the goods
she could not receive the goods which my will contains so if she didn't have the divine will
within her she she couldn't have all the goods that it contains either and if
may it never be she had some seed which is not good that's hebrews 1214
hebrews 12 nothing unholy or unworthy can enter the divine will
if she had some seed which is not good she would be an intruder without nobility and decorum
therefore she herself feeling ashamed would go out of it nor would she have any taste and
contentment that taste there is satisfaction and contentment which keeping within herself
things that are extraneous to my will okay so he says that when we allow something in us which is
not right for the divine will do we ourselves pull out we do it quite naturally just as the souls
in pargotry pull quite naturally away from the divine presence when they can no long when they
can not at that particular time endure the purity of God's gaze so they they agree to go back into
the flames to be purified to come back and so they keep trying to come back the more we pray for
them the more they try to come back and then eventually they can enter into the presence of God
okay so there's no way that we can live in the divine will if there's anything contrary to the
divine will in us it's actually that simple so this is why i have marked even the drops of your blood
your bones and your heartbeats and the marks of the are these eyes of light so that nothing
nothing may come from you which is not holy and not directed to me so if he has given her eyes
of light in everything her blood her bones and everything that means he has given her complete
self-knowledge she can actually say one of the greatest gifts God can give us a self-knowledge
that we can actually see the spots we can see them very easily in others but not in ourselves
and self-knowledge is a great gift from God
so then louisa said Jesus carried me outside of myself letting me see how everything is all
upset that means in the political and social spheres in the world okay why is it all upset
because it's outside of god's will they're not they're not even doing themselves affair and how
they are plotting more wars and revolutions of course that's the second world war so i want to
give you isiah 46 10 that the lord is revealing ahead of time and jesus did a great deal to persuade
them but seeing their obstinacy he withdrew from them now to withdraw the divine presence
is the worst punishment of all so i want to give you i've given you this before Ezekiel 10 and 11
and Romans chapter one where the lord says that god abandoned them he says at three times
in chapter one of the Romans since they foul way of life that was going on in Rome at the time
didn't deserve god's presence so he withdrew from them
Romans chapter one and Ezekiel chapters 10 and 11 and now if god's presence is withdrawn from us
grace is withdrawn because jesus has told us since volume two that he is grace okay so it might be
good to say grace is withdrawn and and if grace is withdrawn of course human beings kill each other
that's the awful thing and she said oh my god what sad times i believe that man has never reached
such an excess of perfity before now understood wanting the destruction of his own being and you
see that our problem is that our wars become more and more destructive we have the ability now to
destroy the planet which we never had before so in the final paragraph louisa is reminded that she
has a double office one is the office of being a victim soul and the other is the office of being
a daughter of the divine will you see when we started out in volume one she was only called to be a
victim soul as you move on towards chapters volumes six to 11 her mission is gradually changed into
being a daughter of the divine will so now she has the two offices okay so after this louisa said
i was in fear that my sweet jesus wouldn't come more so since i felt that my sufferings had become
milder and were as though asleep so i said to myself if what i saw is true according to the other
times in order to give course to to justice he probably will not come and will let me share
his pains at long last she can work it out for herself he's not coming because he wants to do
justice this is the first time and 14 volumes that louisa comes to this conclusion i thought
wow i'm not the only one that's a slow learner but it gives me comfort i don't know about you
and jesus coming back and seeing me very oppressed said my daughter don't fear
don't you remember that you occupy a double office one of victims soul you'd have to add
because victim has a new meaning for us and the other the greater one is that of living in the
divine will to give me back the complete glory of all creation therefore if you are not in one
office together with me i keep you in the other one now what is there this is funny the relationship
between jesus and louisa i just think is fascinating she has after 14 volumes come to the conclusion
that was perfectly obvious to anybody reading it that when he isn't coming he's doing justice
okay and now that she's come to that conclusion he shifts her focus completely and says well actually
you know it means that you've shifted from one vocation to the other it's fascinating
so if you're not in the office of victim you're in the office of living in the divine will
and as of course we're going to the the highest volumes it's totally in the divine will she's
she's actually left the victim thing behind and therefore if you are not in one office
together me i with me i keep you in the other one at most there might be a pause of sufferings
with regard to the office of victim therefore do not fear and calm yourself you have to tell her
that all the time because she's she's an Italian and the Italians are very emotional and calming
themselves it's not exactly a natural gift for them i don't know if you know them
so september the 24th 1922 i go to give you my own heading for this evil comes from the rejection
of divine will this is the heading for this whole piece
so evil comes from the rejection of divine will as i was in my usual state louise has said my sweet
jesus made himself seen stripped shivering with cold telling me my daughter cover me warm me for
i am cold see with sin the creature had stripped herself of all goods genesis three seven and eleven
where adam and eve discovered they were naked and the lord said who told you you were naked
where did you get this knowledge from so genesis three seven two eleven um i also want to give you
a very interesting text in revelation 16 16 and i always connect these two genesis three
and revelation 16 because john says something that if you take it by itself will leave you just saying
what on earth is he talking about he says that when jesus comes make sure you have your clothes on
and so you could misread it and that john is saying now no streaking please you know
whereas clothes means your garment of salvation the garment of grace stripped means no garment of
salvation no garment of grace is that okay that's what it means and that's what you mean by stripped
of all goods and jesus is going to explain that that's why he accepted the stripping in the passion
to make reparation for this uh so with sin the creature had stripped herself of all goods
and i wanted to form for her a more beautiful garment weaving it with my works beating it with
my blood and adorning it with my wounds this is the garment of salvation and that's the meaning of
the white cloth of course that we put on an infant in baptism the pot is not my sorrow in seeing this
garment so beautiful being rejected as creatures content themselves with remaining naked and it
starts with parents not having the understanding to baptize their children and i myself see
feel stripped in them because graces are now pouring of god and so if the grace is not there
then the lord feels stripped in these people and i feel they're cold therefore clothes me he said
for i need it luisa said how can i clothe you i don't have anything and he said indeed you can
clothe me you have my whole will in your power absorb the divine will within you that's your fusing
and then release it and you will make me the most beautiful garments fantastic but first of all
fuse in the divine will but then you've got to use it to help everybody else you will you will make
the most beautiful garment of heaven and divine and how warmed i will be and i will clothe you
with the garment of my will is that a wonderful thing you could pray for the nation that's gone
into the ways of sin lord clothe them with the garment of grace clothe them again with the garment
of salvation but enter into the divine will first it's only as you go over these texts more and more
and more that you sort of come to grips with how to use it because i think ireland needs the garment
of grace and salvation very badly doesn't it and so i will clothe you with the garment of my will
so that we may be clothed with the same uniform that's the divine will
okay and it's only when we're wearing the uniform of the divine will that we can
clothe others with grace so this is why i want it from you so that i may give it to you with justice
if you clothe me it's just that i clothe you to repay you for what you've done for me all the evil
in man is that he has lost the seed of my will therefore he does nothing but cover himself
with the greatest crimes which degrade him and make him act like a madman now it's a very important
word we would say a fool wouldn't we okay don't forget that jesus was declared a madman by herad
in the passion and he accepted that to heal our madness okay so just say herad in the passion
okay um oh how many follies they are about to commit and this is a just penalty since they want
to have their own self as god that's otolotry a ut o l a t or y the final insult to god's otolotry
a ut o l a t or y so we come to september the 27th 1922 and the subject here is love
i'm giving you these headings so that when you start doing research looking for titles
you'll see the title on top of your thing is that okay notice i said you okay you heard that one
i felt in bitter to the summit louisa said of the privation of my sweet jesus and the pain was so
great that i began to speak nonsense to the point of saying that he didn't love me that is nonsense
isn't it that he no longer cared about me and that i loved him more of which he goes on with that
i had just fascinated it's true that my love is small just a shadow a tiny little drop a small
scent but this is because my being is made this way now look at the way she's able to throw it back
at him and but who can say all the nonsense i was speaking it was the delirium of the fever produced
by his privation that made me say silly things that delirium is sam 62 even my body pines for you
like a dry weary land without water and sam 42 i have nothing but tears for my bread
night and day sam 62 and sam 42 then after i struggled very much my sweet jesus came and told
me my daughter i want to see whether you love me more he oh he says i'm going to take you on
and as he was saying this the person of jesus multiplied so much so that i saw him on the right
on the left in the heart there was no part of me or place in which i couldn't see him
and all together were saying i love you i love you i love you but this was nothing since jesus
contains the creative power the whole of creation was repeating together i love you i love you i love
you heaven and earth pilgrim and blessed souls all together in chorus as if it won echo repeated
the i love you with that love with which jesus loves you so all creation now i call this at the
rounds backways because we do this to the lord and here's jesus doing it luisa why because the divine
will is inside her so luisa said i remain confused in the face of so much love and jesus added say
it repeat that you love me more multiply yourself so that you can give me as much love as i can give
you and luisa said my jesus forgive me i don't know how to multiply myself i do not possess the
creative power so i have nothing in my power how can i give you as much love as you give to me
i too know that my love is a shadow compared to yours but the pain of your privation makes me
delirious and makes me say silly things therefore don't leave me alone without you anymore if you
don't want me to speak nonsense and jesus interrupting me said i am my daughter you do not know in what
a struggle i find myself my love pushes me to the point of using violence to make myself come to you
while my justice almost forbids me because human beings are about to reach the excesses of evil
and do not deserve mercy now of course if luisa had had any idea of what i've gone on in the
concentration camps she might have agreed to justice okay the excesses of evil and do not
deserve mercy which overflows upon them when i come to let you share in my pain so this year isiah
4610 again which they themselves inflict on me you must know that the leaders of the nations
are conspiring together to destroy people and to plot troubles against my church and to obtain
the intent they want to use the help of foreign powers the point in which the world
finds itself is terrible and therefore have patience so she's she's shown the preparations
for world war two okay and the interesting thing is that when they get to the stage of world war
two jesus will say to her no more about that now we're not going to even deal with it let them
kill one another as much as they like you and i are going to create a future full of hope for them
it's beautiful and they concentrate completely on the divine world it's magnificent so all these
prophecies about chastisements and everything it's all ahead of time that's why i give you isiah 4610
and amos 37 uh october the third 1922 is all about blessed mother which is nice so this is a relief
after chastisement uh continue in my usual state i felt oppressed because blessed jesus often allows
that i suffer while the confessor is present now this is the first time she says this um
it seemed in the volumes before now that louisa was suffering privately and that the priest would
come the following morning and release her but now she's saying that uh she's taken into the
sufferings with the priest actually present and i lamented to jesus saying my love i pray you i
implore you do not again allow that i suffer in the presence of anyone let everything pass
between you and me and that you alone are aware of my pains oh please make me content give me your
word that you will not do it anymore even more make me suffer twice as much i'm happy as long as
everything is hidden between you and me that's okay for if it's if it's just something involving
herself what this is involving a major revelation to the world so it has got to be made known so
jesus interrupting me said uh my daughter do not lose heart when my will wants it you must surrender
in other words the priest has to see what's going on besides this is nothing other than
a step of my life my very hidden life my interior pains and everything i did always had at least one
or two spectators now one would be blessed mother and two would it be adding st joseph okay and this
with reason out of necessity and in order to obtain the purpose of my pains themselves the first
spectator was my celestial father okay from whom nothing could escape and since he himself
was the one who inflicted those pains on me he was the actor that's the doer and the spectator
if my father had seen and known nothing how could i have satisfied him and given him glory
how could i bend him to mercy for mankind in the sight of my pains their purpose would have failed
secondly my mother was the spectator of all my pains of my hidden life
and this was necessary having come from heaven to earth to suffer not for myself but for the good
of others i had to have at least one creature in whom i was to place that good which my pains
contained and therefore move my dear mother to thank me praise me love me and bless me
letting her admire the excess of my goodness so much so that captured enraptured and moved
at the sight of my pains she prayed me that in the face of the great good which my pains brought to her
that i would not exempt her from being identified with my own pains in order to suffer them to repay
me and to be my perfect imitator if my mother had seen nothing i would not have had my first imitator
not a thank you or praise my pains and the good they contained would have remained without effect
because since no one would have known them i could have not taken the first prop i could not have made
the first prop and the purpose of the great good which the creature was to receive would have been
lost see how necessary it was that at least one creature be aware of my pains now he doesn't mention
saint joseph but saint joseph had to have seen them okay and the reason why he's isolating blessed
mother as distinct from joseph is that she was the one through whom the whole of redemption came
so she had a primary purpose in it just as louisa has with the kingdom of the divine will
if for me it was so i wanted to be also for you in other words he's been telling louisa from the
beginning of these writings that she is the repeater of his life even more i tell you that i want
the confessor acting together with me both as spectator and the pository of the pains i make you
suffer so that he too may share in their good and having him with me i may excite him more
in the faith and infuse in him light and love to make him understand the truths i keep manifesting
to you so what jesus is saying is the priest is not there as a spectator he's part of this mystery
and the more he enters into it the more he himself will benefit as well and we have loads of evidence
of that in the church with the what i call the saintly couples you know who worked with each other
and a captain of siena and her her her spiritual direction pina fort i think his name is raiment
of pina fort i think his name is and he became a blessed i don't know why they didn't finish it
off and canonize them you know because if you're in heaven you're in heaven and you've got many of
these throughout history that the person who would be involved in helping the saint also becomes a saint
okay and you know what there's a saying in the church that to live with the saint you have to
be a martyr so you're going to be a saint one way or the other so if you're looking after somebody
who needs an enormous amount of help you've entered into martyrdom okay and actually if you look at it
if you look at it as martyrdom it actually helps so that you're not staying outside of the mystery
okay so we'll just finish this and then we'll stop uh louisa said on hearing this i remained
oppressed more than ever and while i hoped for mercy i found justice and unshakeability now i
don't know where these guys get the words would you put immutability god is immutable he doesn't change
uh i found this immutability on the part of jesus oh god what pain she said in seeing me more
afflicted he added my daughter is this the love you have for me oh oh remember she was saying that
she loved him more the times are so very sad and the troubles which are coming are too horrifying
and when you are not able to prevent the whole course of my justice by yourself the two of you
will be able to do it the two of you is the priest and yourself that's very important
maria val torta had her priest as well father milliniori okay the two of you will be able to do
it and you yourself uh should ask me to make your suffer now louisa has avoided that all the time
she used to say no no if if obedience tells me elder you know so the priest has to do it and jesus
says why can't you do it yourself in other words why don't you take the initiative you yourself
should ask me to suffer therefore resign yourself also in this and have patience your jesus wants it
and that's enough so i want to give you a matthew 18 19 to 20 where two or three are gathered in my
name i am there and if two of you agree concerning any matter i will ratify it in heaven so he wants
the two the lord likes producing saints and clusters matthew 18 verses 19 to 20 now i leave it there
because the next one is very long.